His brother needed somebody last minute, because a guy bailed on him. Jeff also had somebody bail on him. He'd moved back home for the summer, for this girl he liked.
他兄弟临时需要人手，因为有个家伙放了他鸽子。杰夫也被人放过鸽子。他夏天刚搬回家，为了一个他喜欢的女孩。
And it became, like, really apparent right away that that wasn't going to work out.
很快就很明显，那段感情是不会有结果的。
So he had some time on his hands. His brother was doing a research study on black bears. His brother was a wildlife biologist and offered him this job as a field tech.
所以他闲了下来。他兄弟正在做一项关于黑熊的研究。他兄弟是位野生动物生物学家，向他提供了一份外勤技术员的工作。
And a summer working with black bears was a dream, so--
能过一个研究黑熊的暑假简直是梦想，所以——
That wouldn't be a dream for everybody. Why was that a dream for you?
这对每个人来说都不是梦想。为什么那对你来说是梦想？
Oh, I just think bears are the coolest animals. They're so cool. Black bears are, like, so cool, how fast they can climb a tree. Like, their ears-- I love their-- bears' ears. I just love everything about bears.
哦，我只是觉得熊是最酷的动物。它们太酷了。黑熊，真的很酷，它们爬树的速度那么快。还有它们的耳朵——我喜欢它们的——熊耳朵。我喜欢关于熊的一切。
So Jeff loves bears. His brother, Wes, studies bears. Jeff is the younger brother. Wes is the older brother. Wes's research was to track where bears were in Bryce Canyon National Park in Utah. Here he is.
所以杰夫喜欢熊。他的兄弟韦斯研究熊。杰夫是弟弟，韦斯是哥哥。韦斯的研究是追踪犹他州布莱斯峡谷国家公园里的熊。他就是韦斯。
There was a bear that had broken into a tent, swatted a woman while she was sleeping, really scared her. And so the idea was to collar some bears, track them, see where they're going, how they're spending their time.
曾经有一只熊闯入帐篷，在一名女子睡觉时拍了她一下，把她吓坏了。所以当时的计划是给一些熊戴上项圈，追踪它们，看看它们去哪，把时间花在哪儿。
If they could figure that out, the park could relocate campsites away from those areas and post signs. So Wes and Jeff spent a summer putting collars with GPS devices onto a bunch of wild bears. And then in the winter, they had to go back and check on the bears, do a quick exam, make sure their collars weren't too tight once the bears fattened up for winter, swap out any old collars that needed new batteries.
如果他们能搞清楚，公园就能把露营地搬离那些区域并竖起警示牌。于是韦斯和杰夫花了一个夏天给一群野生熊戴上了带有GPS设备的项圈。然后在冬天，他们不得不回去检查那些熊，做一个简单的体检，确保熊在为过冬增肥后项圈没有太紧，并更换那些需要新电池的旧项圈。
And it turns out the easiest way to do that is to visit the bears when they're hibernating in their dens. In most bear dens, that job isn't actually too difficult or scary. The dens are small, like a cavity in some rock or under a tree, Wes says.
事实证明，最简单的办法就是在熊冬眠时去探望它们。韦斯说，在大多数熊洞里，这项工作其实并不太困难或恐怖。这些洞很小，就像岩石间的空洞或树下的空间。
And they're generally shallow enough that I can just-- I have a pole that has a syringe on the end of it. I can just extend that pole and sedate the bear from outside of the den. I don't generally even have to go inside.
而且它们通常足够浅，我可以用——我有一根末端带有注射器的杆子。我可以直接伸出那根杆子，在洞外给熊打麻醉剂。通常我甚至不需要进去。
Generally.
通常情况下。
But then, you get a couple dens where it's like you're the only thing between the bear and the exit. And that's when it gets kind of sketchy.
但后来，你会遇到几个洞，那种情况下，你是熊和出口之间唯一的东西。那时候情况就变得有点危险了。
And that's what happened in this case.
而这就是这次发生的事情。
Oh, this one was, like, on another level, though. This one was crazy.
哦，不过这一个简直是另一个级别的。这一个太疯狂了。
This one happened on a wintry day. The two of them headed out to see bear number 95 in their study. They saw a signal on the GPS, climbed maybe 1,000 feet up a steep hillside to get to him in the snow. It was hard and cold. And then they struggled to find any opening at all in the rock that could be a den, because it's just a blanket of snow everywhere. They searched for maybe half an hour.
这次发生在一个冬日。他们两人出发去寻找研究中的95号熊。他们看到GPS信号，在雪地里爬了大约1000英尺陡峭的山坡才找到它。路很难走，天气很冷。然后他们费力地寻找任何可能是洞穴的岩石开口，因为到处都是厚厚的积雪。他们找了大概半个小时。
And then Wes is, like, standing on this, like, tiny little opening. And then I see these branches right by his feet. And a lot of times, bears will, like, bring branches into their den. So I'm like, Wes, like, I think you're standing on top of the den. (CHUCKLING) And he's just like, no way.
然后韦斯就站在一个——一个小小的开口上。我看到他脚边有树枝。很多时候，熊会把树枝带进洞里。所以我说，韦斯，我觉得你正站在洞口上。（轻笑）而他说，不可能。
They clear away the snow, and it's an opening the size of a manhole cover, going into the side of a sandstone cliff.
他们扫开雪，那是一个井盖大小的洞口，通往砂岩悬崖的一侧。
And then we crouched down and looked. And, like-- I mean, you could only see, like, 20 feet in, and it's just black. So honestly, this den-- it would be terrifying to go in it if you, like, didn't know anything was in there. And you know that there's a bear in there, so that just intensifies it so much more. But it's like even if there wasn't a bear, I'd be like, this is scary.
然后我们蹲下看了看。我的意思是，你只能看进去20英尺，里面是一片漆黑。说实话，如果你不知道里面有什么，进去这个洞会很恐怖。你知道里面有一只熊，那只会让这种恐怖加剧。但即使没有熊，我也会觉得，这太吓人了。
Wes and Jeff discuss whether they're going to go into this hole. Black bears aren't like grizzlies. They almost never attack people. But going into this very unusual den where the bear might feel trapped or threatened and have no way out except through them-- that's a choice.
韦斯和杰夫讨论是否要进这个洞。黑熊不像灰熊。它们几乎从不攻击人。但进入这个非常不寻常的洞穴，熊可能会感到被困或受到威胁，除了经过他们之外别无去路——这是一个选择。
Jeff does talk back to Wes way more than any normal field tech would, because he's his brother. But Wes is the boss, and he's like, we came this far, and we really do need to change that bear's collar.
杰夫回嘴韦斯的频率确实比任何普通的技术员都要高，因为他是他弟弟。但韦斯是老板，他说，我们都到这儿了，我们确实需要更换那只熊的项圈。
And I start crawling in, looking for the back of the den, looking for the bear, and it's just not there. And this hole just plunges into darkness. My headlamp only goes so far. And I just keep going. And immediately, I realize, like, shit, this is a really, really long den. This is much longer than anything I've ever seen or even heard of.
我开始爬进去，寻找洞穴的深处，寻找那只熊，但它不在那儿。这个洞不断深入黑暗。我的头灯照不了多远。我继续前进。我立刻意识到，糟了，这是一个非常、非常长的洞。这比我见过甚至听说过的任何洞都要长。
How long?
有多长？
This thing extends 80 feet back, and at the end of it, it's just pitch black. You kind of-- you really do have to suppress a lot of primal stuff that's telling you this is a place where you are not supposed to be. This is not a place for humans.
这个东西向后延伸了80英尺，尽头是一片漆黑。你确实需要抑制住很多原始的本能，它们在告诉你，这地方不是你该来的。这不是人类该待的地方。
Wes is in front, big brother, scientist. Jeff's behind-- little brother, assistant. And they're army-crawling, because the tunnel is too low to stand up in. It's pretty cramped.
韦斯在前面，哥哥，科学家。杰夫在后面——弟弟，助理。他们采取匍匐前进的姿势，因为隧道太低无法站立。里面很挤。
And you know that feeling where you're in your belly in a tunnel, inching towards a bear? No, of course not. You don't know that feeling. Who has done that?
你明白那种腹部贴地在隧道里向着熊挪动的感觉吗？不，当然不。你不知道那种感觉。谁做过那种事？
But you have been in this situation of moving toward something scary or dreadful ahead. And now, you have gotten yourself in it. You can't turn back. You have to keep moving. You just have to deal. And that is what today's show is about. We have this story, and then we have another one in the second half of the show. And yes, it's This American Life from WBEZ Chicago, Ira Glass.
但你肯定有过走向恐惧或可怕之物的情况。现在，你把自己置于其中了。你不能回头。你必须继续前进。你只能去应对。这就是今天节目的主题。我们有这个故事，节目下半场还有另一个故事。没错，这是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Anyway, so they're edging towards this bear, right? The tunnel was gently sloping downward. And the smell-- you may be wondering about the smell. It's like wet earth, musty.
总之，他们正在向那只熊靠近，对吧？隧道向下倾斜。至于气味——你可能好奇气味。就像湿润的泥土，带着霉味。
The bear brings in a nest of, like, pine tree boughs and other sticks and stuff. So it does kind of smell cedary and nice, too.
熊会带进一个由松枝和其他树枝之类的东西筑成的窝。所以它闻起来也有点像雪松味，还不错。
Hmm.
嗯。
Like, it's musty, but it's honestly not as bad as what you would think. Because when a bear goes into hibernation-- Wes will give you a lot more scientific name on this, but they create, like, a butt plug of, like, poop, so that they won't poop the entire time they're in their den. So there's, like, no feces or urine in there. So it honestly isn't terrible.
闻起来发霉，但老实说，没你想的那么糟糕。因为当熊进入冬眠时——韦斯会给你更多专业名词——它们会制造一个像排泄物塞子一样的东西，这样它们在洞里的时候就不会排便。所以里面没有粪便或尿液。所以坦白讲，并不难闻。
They may be 15, 20, 25 feet into the tunnel, and Wes's headlamp points at the far end.
他们可能已经进入隧道25英尺了，韦斯的头灯照向了最深处。
And I just see these two green eyes at the very end of this tunnel, staring back at me. And the thing about these hibernating bears is they-- bears don't hibernate very deeply. So if a bear hears you approaching its den, it can come out of that hibernation, and generally, within 5 to 10 minutes, they can be mobile.
我看到隧道尽头有两只绿色的眼睛，盯着我看。关于这些冬眠的熊，它们——熊的冬眠并不非常深。所以如果熊听到你靠近它的洞穴，它就能从冬眠中醒来，通常在5到10分钟内，它们就能活动了。
And so this bear was awake. And they have the tapetum lucidum, which is the thing you see in cats' eyes or deer eyes or whatever that reflects light back at you. And they reflect a really kind of green glow. And so it's just, again, the stuff of nightmares. Like, you're crawling down a deep, dark hole in the mountains, and there's two green eyes shining back at you.
所以这只熊醒着。它们有照膜，就是你在猫眼或鹿眼之类看到的反射光的东西。它们反射出一种非常绿色的光。所以，这又是噩梦般的场景。你在山里爬进一个又深又黑的洞，那里有两只绿眼睛在盯着你。
The light starts to catch these two eyeballs at the very end of the den that are just, like, gleaming back at us. So at that point, I'm, like, terrified. And I start kind of freaking out. I start saying, Wes, this is crazy, this is crazy. Like, I don't know about this.
光线开始照到洞穴尽头那两颗正对着我们闪闪发光的眼珠。那一刻，我很恐慌。我开始有点崩溃。我开始说，韦斯，这太疯狂了，这太疯狂了。我不知道该怎么办。
And Jeff just started saying, we shouldn't be here, we shouldn't be here, we shouldn't be here. It was like a mantra that he was repeating.
杰夫开始说，我们不该在这儿，我们不该在这儿，我们不该在这儿。就像他在重复一段咒语。
And, like, I keep saying that.
而且，我一直在重复那句话。
And it was starting to really freak me out. Like, I was trying to summon all this courage and draw on all my experience, and then I have him behind me telling me that we just should not be in there. And so I turned around.
这开始让我真的感到恐慌。我试图鼓起所有的勇气，利用我所有的经验，但他却在我身后告诉我，我们根本不该待在那儿。所以我转过身。
And then Wes just goes, Jeff, shut up. [CHUCKLES] So then my immediate response was like, you're so brave. [CHUCKLES]
然后韦斯说，杰夫，闭嘴。（轻笑）我当时的第一反应是，你太勇敢了。（轻笑）
And then, he just started repeating, you're the bravest person I've ever met, you're the bravest person I've ever met. And that helped, actually. That made me feel a lot better.
然后，他开始重复，你是见过最勇敢的人，你是见过最勇敢的人。这确实有帮助。这让我感觉好多了。
It's funny how he needs to keep saying something to have some place to put his fear.
真有趣，他需要不断说点什么，好给自己找个地方安放恐惧。
Yeah. Yeah. I think, for him, he needed to vocalize that, and for me, I was really going inward and just trying to focus on the bear. And I was looking for any cues that that bear was going to be aggressive. And at that point, you leave.
是的。是的。我想，对他来说，他需要把那些话说出来，而对我来说，我确实在向内收敛，试着专注于那只熊。我在寻找任何那只熊要表现出攻击性的迹象。如果那样，你就得离开。
What are you watching for?
你在观察什么？
They make a really distinctive [HUFFING] sound when they're really, really upset. And then, they also can-- they make this really interesting jaw-popping noise, too. It literally clacks its jaws. It pops its jaws.
当它们非常、非常愤怒时，会发出一种非常明显的（喷气）声。然后，它们还可以——它们会发出这种非常有趣的颌骨碰撞声。它们真的会磕碰颌骨。
It's kind of like a [CLICKING] sound. And then from there, it proceeds to swatting the ground with its paws. And then if it is still upset, it'll bluff-charge you. And a bluff charge is just where the bear comes at you, and then stops short.
就像一种（咔哒）声。然后在此基础上，它会开始用爪子拍打地面。如果它依然愤怒，它会虚张声势地冲向你。虚张声势的冲锋就是熊冲向你，然后在最后停下。
Are you terrified?
你感到恐怖吗？
Oh, yeah. Oh, yeah, I was absolutely terrified. I have a video that I took when I got close to the bear. I took a quick video from my phone. And at the very end of it, you just hear me say, this is so scary.
哦，是的。哦，是的，我绝对感到恐怖。我接近那只熊时拍过一个视频。我用手机拍了个短视频。视频最后，你能听到我说，这太吓人了。
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
（音频播放）
(OUT OF BREATH) OK. Oh, this is so fucking scary. This is so scary.
（上气不接下气）好吧。哦，这他妈太吓人了。这太吓人了。
[END PLAYBACK]
（播放结束）
Because it really was. It was terrifying.
因为确实如此。这太恐怖了。
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
（音频播放）
[PANTING] Oh my gosh.
（喘气）我的天啊。
[END PLAYBACK]
（播放结束）
All of my body, a lot of my psyche was saying, you absolutely need to get out of this den. It's this feeling of being a soft, pink human being in a place where we don't belong.
我的整个身体、大部分心理都在说，你绝对需要离开这个洞。这是一种身为软弱的粉红色人类，置身于不属于我们地方的感觉。
Of course, Wes, being in the tunnel with this bear-- he's a bear expert. And he's thought some about what this experience must have been like for the bear.
当然，作为在隧道里和熊在一起的人——韦斯是熊类专家。他想过这种经历对熊来说会是什么样。
Where these black bears live, they're top dog. There's nothing bigger or more dangerous than them. And so they don't have stuff that crawls into their dens and gets closer and closer to them.
在这些黑熊生活的地方，它们是老大。没有比它们更大或更危险的了。所以它们没有会爬进洞穴、离它们越来越近的东西。
So it must be a very unique experience for them as well. Like, I'm obviously a bear. Like, what the hell is this thing doing in here?
所以对它们来说，这肯定也是一种非常独特的体验。就像，我显然是一只熊。到底是什么东西在这儿？
Wait, when the bear sees you, like, it knows it can kick your ass, right? Like, it can just look at you, and it doesn't even-- without even thinking or doing any math in its head or something, it just sees your size, and it just knows, well, you're not a threat. But then, is it scared?
等等，当熊看到你时，它知道它能轻松干掉你，对吧？它只需要看着你，甚至不用思考，不用在大脑里做算术，它看到你的体型，就知道你不是威胁。但它害怕吗？
Yeah, you know, I think the thing that we have to realize with wild animals is that for them, a fight means much more than can I win or will I lose. It's like, am I going to be injured in this? Because for any animal, bears included, if they sustain a big injury in any kind of scuffle or fight or whatever, that could be a death sentence for them. Because then they no longer have the ability to feed or escape or even move. And so they tend to be very risk-averse.
是的，你知道，我认为我们需要意识到的是，对于野生动物来说，战斗意味着比“我赢还是输”多得多。意思是，我会在其中受伤吗？因为对任何动物，包括熊，如果它们在任何斗殴或争斗中受了重伤，那对它们来说可能就是死刑判决。因为那样它们就失去了进食、逃跑甚至移动的能力。所以它们往往非常规避风险。
So Wes and Jeff keep army-crawling forward with a syringe full of sedative on the end of a 7-foot pole. And finally, Wes gets close enough to jab it into the bear. Mission accomplished, right?
所以韦斯和杰夫继续匍匐前进，拿着一根7英尺长的杆子，顶端装有装满镇静剂的注射器。最后，韦斯靠得足够近，给熊打了一针。任务完成，对吧？
But we jab it. The bear doesn't react at all.
但我们刺进去了。熊一点反应都没有。
Doesn't flinch, and most important, does not fall asleep, partly because it'd gotten so big since they'd last seen it-- like, 350 pounds-- which would require way more sedative than West gave it. So the two of them head back out of the cave to prepare another dose of sedative, which they definitely are going to need. That job goes to Jeff, the little brother.
没退缩，最重要的是，没有睡着。部分原因在于它自上次见到后长得太大了——大约350磅——这需要的镇静剂比韦斯给它的要多得多。所以他们两人折回洞外准备第二剂镇静剂，这是他们肯定会需要的。这项工作交给了弟弟杰夫。
And it was something I was fully capable of doing, but I think I was still just dialed up all the way to 11, with all my emotions, and my thoughts weren't clear. So I was doing a terrible job.
这本是我完全能做到的事情，但我认为当时我的情绪依然处于极度紧张的状态，思绪不够清晰。所以我做得很糟。
Like your hands aren't totally steady?
就像你的手完全不稳？
Yeah, I'm just making a mess. I'm, like, fumbling around. And eventually, the bear, like, makes its way all the way through the 80 feet of den and starts coming out.
是的，我把事情弄得一团糟。我在笨手笨脚地忙活。最终，那只熊沿着80英尺长的洞穴往外走，开始出来了。
This is not the plan. It would be very bad for a tranq'd-out bear to leave its den at all. It could easily wander off and get lost in the snow in the middle of winter. And Wes and Jeff-- remember, they're bear guys. They do anything they can think of so the bears in this research don't get hurt by it, and experience the minimum amount of discomfort or stress.
这不是计划。如果一只被打了麻醉的熊离开洞穴，那将非常糟糕。它很容易走失，在冬天冻死在雪地里。而韦斯和杰夫——记住，他们是熊专家。他们会想尽一切办法，不让研究中的熊受到伤害，并使它们经历最低程度的不适或压力。
They have another field tech with them who's been waiting outside the tunnel. And Wes orders that guy now, keep the bear in the den. And the guy starts swatting at the bear with a plastic shovel to keep it from emerging.
他们身边还有另一位外勤技术员，一直在隧道外等待。韦斯命令那个人，现在，把熊挡在洞里。那人开始用塑料铲子拍打熊，以阻止它出来。
And it just does not care. It's not even registering that he's there and just keeps walking past him.
但它完全不在乎。它甚至没察觉到他在那儿，径直从他身边走了过去。
Wow.
哇。
So yeah. So at that point, I ran. And the thing that I really didn't want to have happen was the drug take hold while this bear was trying to get away and have it tumble down the hillside or down a cliffside or something like that. I just wasn't willing to let that happen.
所以，是的。在那一点上，我跑过去了。我最不想发生的事情就是药物在熊试图逃跑时起效，导致它滚下山坡或悬崖什么的。我绝不允许这种情况发生。
So I ran and actually grabbed the bear by its back legs and pulled them out from under it. And then I straddled the bear and pushed its head down into the snow. In the meantime, I had sent--
所以我跑过去，真的抓住了熊的后腿，把它从下面拽了出来。然后我骑在熊背上，把它的头按进雪里。同时，我派——
Wait, wait, wait, wait. What are you-- what are you talking about? You're able to do that because the bear is kind of like-- is the bear walking like a sort of cartoon drunk bear kind of thing? Like, it's staggering along?
等等，等等，等等。你在说什——你在说什么？你能做到这一点是因为那只熊有点像——那只熊走起来像卡通里的醉熊吗？踉踉跄跄的？
Yeah, that's honestly exactly how it was walking. That's a perfect representation.
是的，老实说，它走起来就是那样。那是一个完美的比喻。
[CHUCKLING]
（轻笑）
So he's on top of this bear, straddling it, holding its collar and head down in the snow. He's actually gotten a second dose of sedative into him by then, but the bear is still awake. And Wes then looks over at Jeff, who is so panicked that he has dropped the entire case of drugs. Jeff is supposed to be preparing a third dose.
所以他骑在熊背上，跨坐在它上面，按着它的项圈和头部埋在雪里。他当时已经给它打了第二剂镇静剂，但熊还清醒着。韦斯看了一眼杰夫，杰夫已经吓坏了，把整盒药都扔了。杰夫本该准备第三剂的。
And I just yell at Jeff. I say, Jeff, come grab this bear. I'll do the drugs.
我冲杰夫大喊。我说，杰夫，快来抓住这只熊。我来处理药。
Kind of an unusual set of sentences to say to anybody.
这对他说的这些话还挺不寻常的。
They switch places. Jeff is now the one straddling the bear, hands on its collar. And the bear gets up and starts to move again.
他们交换了位置。现在杰夫跨坐在熊身上，手抓着它的项圈。熊站起来开始又动了。
And it's almost like-- you know that movie, The Replacements, where Keanu Reeves is a quarterback? Or any of the football movies where the big hefty lineman catches the ball?
这几乎就像——你知道那部电影《替补球员》吗，基努·里维斯是四分卫？或者是任何橄榄球电影里，体型巨大的前锋接住了球？
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
And then they're just, like, slowly moving towards the end zone, and the whole defense jumps on him, and they're just kind of, like, falling off of him and trucking...
然后他们就那样慢慢地向达阵区移动，整个防守组都跳到他身上，他们只是那种，从他身上掉下来，然后拖着……
And he's still going towards the goal line? Yeah,
而他还在向球门线推进？是的，
...is going in a straight line with all these people hanging on him? It's kind of like that. We were just hanging on this black bear, and it's just, like, slowly going in a straight line.
……在所有这些人挂在他身上的情况下，直线前进？有点像那样。我们只是挂在那只黑熊身上，而它就像，慢慢地走直线。
Jeff's holding it by the collar, getting dragged along-- slowing it down a little bit, but that's all he can do, in this thing with this bear where none of the normal rules apply, totally off the map.
杰夫抓着项圈，被拖着走——稍微减慢了它的速度，但他所能做的也只有这些，在这样一个常规规则完全不适用的地方，完全处于地图之外。
I was like, this is what I have to do, but I can't believe I'm doing it. It was, like, surreal. Like, I just-- it's like I was in a dream.
我觉得，这是我必须做的，但我无法相信我在做这事。这很超现实。就像，我只是——就像我身处梦境。
It starts making its way to more of a downward slope, too, so now, it's really hard for me to stop it. And I'm just kind of, like, on the back of it. And it walks straight into a pine tree, and literally, like, couldn't figure out what was going on and just tried to keep walking forward into a tree.
它开始向着更陡的下坡路走，所以现在我很难阻止它了。我有点像，在它背上。它直直地撞进一棵松树里，老实说，它完全没搞清楚发生了什么，只是试图继续向前走进树里。
Wes remembers it more like a juniper bush, but in any case, it does the job. The bear stops, finally passes out on the ground. They do their business, change the collar, examine the bear.
韦斯记得那更像是一丛杜松，但无论如何，这起了作用。熊停下来了，终于倒在地上昏睡过去。他们处理完工作，换上项圈，检查了熊。
And then, so the bear doesn't get lost and confused in the snow when it wakes up, they grab its limbs and drag it 15 yards or so back up the slope to the opening of the tunnel, which is exactly as completely exhausting as you would imagine. It takes maybe half an hour.
然后，为了让熊醒来时不会在雪地里迷路和困惑，他们抓住它的四肢，把它拖回坡上大约15码远的地方，带回洞穴入口，这和你想象的一样耗尽体力。大概花了半个小时。
The temperature is dropping. Wes is worried that the bear might get cold, so he leaves a blanket on top of him before they go.
温度在下降。韦斯担心熊可能会冷，所以他在离开前在它身上盖了一条毯子。
Looking back, what Wes and Jeff both talk about is the terror that they felt in that tunnel. Wes says it was a whole new level of fear he didn't know existed, like the kind of primal fear that, long ago, humans must have had all the time facing off with animals that wanted to kill them and eat them.
回顾过去，韦斯和杰夫谈论的都是他们在隧道里感受到的恐惧。韦斯说那是他不知道存在的一种全新的恐惧水平，就像很久以前人类在面对想要杀死并吃掉它们的动物时，肯定一直存在的那种原始恐惧。
And it's something that we've forgotten, but I think it's something that still sits deep inside of us, that when you do have these experiences with large animals, that it bubbles to the surface. And in a way, it was really intoxicating. I'll tell you, that night, I didn't sleep a wink, because my adrenaline was just coursing through my body. It just made me feel-- honestly, made me feel very alive. And even when I think back on that, I can still remember the feelings I had that night as I went back to my cabin and everything, just how bright the stars seemed and how crisp the air felt. And it really just reminded me how good it is to be alive.
这是一种我们已经忘记的东西，但我认为它仍然深深地藏在我们内心深处，当你与大型动物有这些经历时，它就会浮出水面。某种程度上，这真的很让人着迷。我告诉你，那天晚上我一夜没睡，因为肾上腺素在我体内奔涌。它让我感觉——老实说，让我感觉非常活着。即使现在回想起那天，我依然记得那天晚上回到小屋时的感受，星星显得多么明亮，空气显得多么清新。它真的提醒了我活着是多么美好。
And the bear? The bear was fine. The drugs they gave it, it probably doesn't remember the details of what happened, Wes said. And over a year later, Wes went back to that tunnel when the bear wasn't in it and found the blanket inside. The bear must have liked it a little. It smelled like bear, fur all over it. Wes took it back, kept it as a souvenir. He says it still smells faintly like bear.
那只熊呢？熊没事。韦斯说，给它的药让它可能记不清发生了什么。一年多后，韦斯回到那个熊不在的洞穴，发现了里面的毯子。熊一定有点喜欢它。上面满是熊毛味。韦斯把它带了回去，当成纪念品留着。他说它现在还有淡淡的熊味。
After the break, we have another story of people thrown into a dangerous and utterly foreseeable situation, and how they handle it, in this episode that we're calling "The Bear at the End of the Tunnel." Wes and Jeff, by the way, have a podcast where they tell stories of animal attacks. It's called Tooth and Claw.
广告回来后，我们还有另一个关于人们被迫陷入危险且完全可预见的境地，以及他们如何应对的故事，这集我们称为“隧道尽头的熊”。顺便说一句，韦斯和杰夫有一个讲述动物攻击故事的播客。叫《牙齿与爪子》。
If you enjoyed this story that you just heard, you should know that by their standards, this story was not so special. The ones on their show-- way more eventful. More in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
如果你喜欢刚才听到的故事，你应该知道，以他们的标准来看，这个故事并不算太特别。他们节目里的那些故事——更惊心动魄。节目继续，稍后从芝加哥公共广播电台带来更多内容。
It's This American life from Ira Glass. Today's program, again-- "The Bear at the End of the Tunnel," stories of people who find themselves trapped in some dangerous situation, and now they just have to deal. We have arrived at Act Two of our show. Act Two-- "The Devil's in the Details. And There Are so Many Details."
这是艾拉·格拉斯的《美国生活》。今天的节目，再说一遍——“隧道尽头的熊”，关于人们发现自己被困在某种危险境地，现在他们只能去应对的故事。我们已经进入节目的第二幕。第二幕——“魔鬼藏在细节里，而且细节太多了。”
So a few months ago, we brought you this story from one of our producers, Miki Meek, about an OB/GYN in rural Idaho who was deciding whether or not to leave the state after Roe versus Wade was overturned and abortion was outlawed there.
几个月前，我们播出了我们制片人米基·米克带来的故事，关于一位爱达荷州乡村的妇产科医生，她正在决定在“罗伊诉韦德案”被推翻且堕胎在那里被定为非法后，是否要离开这个州。
I don't want to leave here. I mean, I don't want to leave, but I don't know if I can stay.
我不想离开这儿。我的意思是，我不想离开，但我不知道我还能不能留下。
This OB/GYN, Amelia Huntsberger, was facing in Idaho a set of abortion laws that kicked in after Roe was overturned that are some of the most restrictive in the country. And can I just say, I think when most of us think of these laws, we think of their effect on abortion clinics and abortion care providers. That wasn't this story.
这位妇产科医生，阿米莉亚·亨茨伯格，在爱达荷州面临着一系列在罗伊案被推翻后生效的堕胎法，这些法律是全国最严格的法律之一。我可以说吗，我想当大多数人想到这些法律时，我们想到的是它们对堕胎诊所和堕胎护理提供者的影响。但那不是这个故事。
Amelia was a general OB/GYN at a hospital-- in other words, doing pap smears, birth control, delivering babies. And her hospital did not terminate pregnancies unless there was a medical complication-- which, by the way, is like most hospitals in the United States.
阿米莉亚是一家医院的一般妇产科医生——换句话说，做巴氏涂片，避孕，接生婴儿。除非有医疗并发症，否则她的医院不会终止妊娠——顺便说一句，这和美国大多数医院一样。
But when Roe was overturned and these new laws in Idaho took effect, they defined abortion in the broadest possible terms. It was effectively a complete ban. Even pregnancies that weren't going to be viable could not be terminated.
但是当罗伊案被推翻，爱达荷州的这些新法律生效时，它们以最广泛的可能定义了堕胎。实际上这是一个彻底的禁令。即使是不可能存活的妊娠也无法终止。
And any doctor who performed an abortion, breaking those rules, faced severe consequences. They could lose their medical license, they could go to prison for two to five years, and they could get sued. Family members could sue. If a rape resulted in a pregnancy and the victim decided to get an abortion, the rapist's family could sue the doctor for performing the abortion.
而任何违反规定进行堕胎的医生都会面临严重的后果。他们可能失去行医执照，可能入狱两到五年，还可能被起诉。家庭成员可以起诉。如果强奸导致了怀孕，而受害者决定堕胎，强奸犯的家属可以起诉医生进行了堕胎。
And the problem for Amelia, this OB/GYN, is that she ran into all kinds of situations where, in the course of administering normal health care for her patients, she could run afoul of the law. For instance, if a patient showed up at her hospital miscarrying and bleeding uncontrollably, in the past, Amelia could terminate the pregnancy to stop the bleeding. But now, she could be charged with a felony if she did that, if she did anything to terminate a pregnancy, if it still had a, quote, "fetal heartbeat." That's a phrase in the law, though in the early stages, it's not a heartbeat. It's just electrical activity and some tissue that could eventually become a heart.
而对于这位妇产科医生阿米莉亚来说，问题在于她陷入了各种各样的情况，在为病人提供正常医疗保健的过程中，她可能触犯法律。例如，如果病人来到她的医院流产且出血不止，过去，阿米莉亚可以终止妊娠来止血。但现在，如果她那样做，如果她采取任何措施终止妊娠，而胎儿仍有所谓的“胎儿心跳”，她就可能被控重罪。这是法律中的一个用语，尽管在早期阶段，那并不是心跳。那只是电活动和一些最终可能长成心脏的组织。
So now, when Amelia faced pregnancies with serious complications, situations where the longer she waited to act, the more danger the patient was in, she could no longer just think about what was best for the patient who was in front of her.
所以现在，当阿米莉亚面对有严重并发症的妊娠，那种她等待行动的时间越长、病人就越危险的情况时，她不能再只考虑面前病人的最大利益了。
You know, when you do surgery like that, where somebody is having ongoing active bleeding, that's already high stress. And that sort of high stress-- like, I trained for that. I know what to do with that. I can handle that.
你知道，当你进行那样的手术时，病人正在持续出血，那已经是高压力了。那种高压力——我接受过这方面的训练。我知道该怎么处理。我能应付。
Then you add in this other weird layer of, like, is her brother going to not understand that this was a not-viable pregnancy and that her life was at risk? And what about her mom? What about her partner? What about her sister?
然后你增加了另一个奇怪的层面，比如，她的兄弟会不会不理解这是一次无法存活的妊娠，且她的生命处于危险之中？那她的妈妈呢？她的伴侣呢？她的姐妹呢？
Do these people understand how serious this condition is? Or do they only understand that I removed a pregnancy that had a heartbeat? I don't know. How am I supposed to know?
这些人理解这种情况有多严重吗？还是他们只知道我终止了一个有心跳的妊娠？我不知道。我该怎么知道？
So she worried about getting sued. She worried about getting prosecuted. This came up all the time.
所以她担心被起诉。她担心被刑事追究。这种情况一直都在发生。
At the end of our story back in March, Amelia was still hanging on in Idaho, still deciding. Since then, so much has happened. Just a few weeks after we aired that story, Amelia decided she was going to move away because of Idaho's abortion laws. She was one of the first OB/GYNs in the state to announce she was going.
在三月份我们故事的结尾，阿米莉亚仍然坚持留在爱达荷州，仍在做决定。从那时起，发生了太多的事。在那个故事播出几周后，因为爱达荷州的堕胎法，阿米莉亚决定搬走。她是州内第一批宣布要离开的妇产科医生之一。
About a week after that, something that she feared might happen someday happened a lot quicker than she had imagined. The hospital where she practiced-- Bonner General Health-- announced that it was shutting down its entire labor and delivery department. The hospital cited the new laws as one reason. They said recruiting new doctors would be, quote, "extremely difficult." Finances was the other reason. Since then, all three of the other OB/GYNs who shared a practice with Amelia have left the state.
大约一周后，她曾经担心某天会发生的事情发生得比她想象的快得多。她所在的医院——邦纳综合卫生院——宣布关闭其整个分娩部门。医院引用了新法律作为原因之一。他们说招聘新医生将是，引用的话，“极其困难”。经济状况是另一个原因。从那时起，与阿米莉亚共用诊所的其他三位妇产科医生也都离开了这个州。
What Amelia dreaded most in moving away was, what was going to happen to her patients? How would all this affect everyone in Idaho trying to have a baby? We thought about that for today's show, because what would happen to them?
阿米莉亚搬走时最担心的是，她的病人会怎么样？所有这些将如何影响爱达荷州每个想要生孩子的人？我们为今天的节目想到了这一点，因为她们会发生什么？
This was, in a sense, the bear in the tunnel-- the difficulties and possible danger that all those patients face because of the new laws. And what has unfolded since has been pretty dramatic. Our producer, Miki Meek, went back to talk to patients and to the lawmakers who put them into the situation that they're in in the state. Here's Miki.
从某种意义上说，这就是隧道里的那只熊——所有那些病人因为新法律而面临的困难和潜在危险。而之后发生的事情非常戏剧化。我们的制片人米基·米克回去与州内的病人以及将她们置于这种境地的立法者交谈。这是米基的报道。
I talked to half a dozen pregnant women who'd been planning to deliver at Bonner General and suddenly found themselves contorting their lives around logistical problems they had never imagined facing for something as everyday as trying to have a baby in the state of Idaho. Brooke Macumber is 25 years old and was days away from giving birth when I reached her. Amelia had been her doctor, and Brooke's plan had been to do her prenatal appointments at Bonner General and deliver there, too.
我和六名原本计划在邦纳综合医院分娩的孕妇交谈，她们突然发现自己必须扭曲生活，去处理那些她们从未想象过会面临的后勤问题，为了像在爱达荷州尝试生孩子这样寻常的事情。布鲁克·马坎伯25岁，我联系到她时，距离分娩只剩几天了。阿米莉亚曾是她的医生，布鲁克的计划是在邦纳综合医院进行产前检查并在那里分娩。
But now, the closest Idaho hospital with a labor and delivery department was almost two hours away, in a small city called Coeur d'Alene. She had to take her three little kids with her in the car on a four-hour round trip for every prenatal appointment-- blood pressure, fetal heartbeat. Four hours for a 15-minute check-in.
但现在，最近的拥有分娩部门的爱达荷州医院在近两个小时路程外，在一个叫科达伦的小城市。为了每次产前检查——测血压、听胎心，她不得不带着三个小孩开车进行四小时的往返。四小时只为15分钟的检查。
The days that we would have to go out to Coeur d'Alene, it was, like, from 9:30 to 6 o'clock at night. I would have my sister-- she lives in Spokane, so she's about 35 minutes from Coeur d'Alene. But she would hang out with the kids so I could go to my appointment. And then we would have to go out for lunch or do a picnic, and then go to a park. Because I'm like, they can't just sit in the car for four hours back to back.
我们必须去科达伦的日子，大约从上午9点半到晚上6点。我会让我妹妹——她住在斯波坎，离科达伦大约35分钟——她会陪孩子们玩，这样我才能去检查。然后我们不得不出去吃午饭或去野餐，或者去公园。因为我想，他们不可能连续坐在车里四个小时。
The distance of the hospital also worried her. She was freaked out about not getting to the hospital in time and giving birth on the side of the road. Her labors have always been pretty fast. Would she have time to make it to the hospital?
医院的距离也让她很担心。她非常害怕不能及时赶到医院而在路边分娩。她的产程一直都很快。她会有时间赶到医院吗？
When Brooke got three weeks away from her due date, she couldn't take being on high alert all the time. So she moved in with her mom, who lived two hours away, close to Brooke's new hospital. Brooke took the kids with her.
当距离预产期还有三周时，布鲁克无法忍受一直处于高度警惕状态。于是她搬到了她妈妈家，距离她新的医院只有两个小时车程。布鲁克带着孩子们一起去了。
Her husband couldn't join them because of work, and her mom was working every day. So Brooke was caring for three little kids, basically on her own at eight months pregnant. It was hard to leave her husband. But splitting up their family temporarily was the only solution they could come up with.
她丈夫因为工作无法加入，而她妈妈每天都在工作。所以布鲁克在怀孕八个月时，基本上独自照顾三个小孩。离开丈夫很难。但暂时分居是他们能想到的唯一解决办法。
Me and my husband have never really been apart before, and so being in a bed alone has been strange. And then our two boys-- they've had some trouble sleeping, so they'll wake up in the middle of the night. So then both the boys will crawl into bed with me, and then I wind up, like, on the couch, because I'm like, I need to try to at least get one more hour of rest.
我和我丈夫以前从未真正分开过，所以独自睡在床上很奇怪。然后我们的两个男孩——他们入睡有些困难，所以他们会在半夜醒来。于是两个男孩都会爬到我床上，最后我落得睡在沙发上，因为我想，我至少需要再多睡一个小时。
Bonner General had been the only labor and delivery unit in its region of northern Idaho. When it shut down, it became a statistic in a whole separate longstanding crisis-- the closure of labor and delivery services in rural hospitals all over the country. Nearly half of rural community hospitals no longer offer obstetrics care.
邦纳综合医院曾是北爱达荷州该地区唯一的产科部门。当它关闭时，它成为了整个长期危机的统计数据的一部分——全国各地乡村医院产科服务的关闭。近一半的乡村社区医院不再提供产科服务。
The chaos created by Bonner General's closure for the women I spoke with involved the most basic important stuff-- childcare, money. Some women told me they would lose a day's worth of pay every time they had to drive to an appointment. They talked about having to budget hundreds or even thousands of extra dollars for travel or housing in a place closer to a labor and delivery department, or switching to a midwife not covered by insurance. Or if they went to another state to get care, insurance might not cover that either.
邦纳综合医院的关闭给与我交谈的女性带来的混乱，涉及最基本的重要事情——托儿、钱。一些女性告诉我，每次去检查她们都要损失一天的工资。她们谈到不得不为去离分娩部门更近的地方旅行或住宿额外预算数百甚至数千美元，或者转而选择保险不承保的助产士。或者如果她们去另一个州接受护理，保险可能也不承保。
I talked to one woman who told me she bought helicopter insurance for a medical evacuation flight, in case she started hemorrhaging or had some other kind of emergency complication. Turns out it's cheaper than you'd think-- $75. And she wasn't the only one. Helicopter insurance for normal pregnancies.
我和一位女性交谈，她告诉我她购买了用于医疗撤离航班的直升机保险，以防大出血或出现其他紧急并发症。结果发现它比你想象的便宜——75美元。而她并不是唯一一个。正常怀孕的直升机保险。
This woman's name is Jessie Grossman. She's 32 years old, and this was her first kid. And in Idaho, she worried the abortion laws tied doctors hands in too many cases.
这位女性名叫杰西·格罗斯曼。她32岁，这是她的第一个孩子。而在爱达荷州，她担心堕胎法在太多情况下束缚了医生的手脚。
So I decided-- what I put in my birth plan was that if we do have to transfer to the hospital, I want to be taken to Washington. Like, I can be less worried about dying, basically.
所以我决定——我在产前计划中写的是，如果我们真的必须转院，我希望被送到华盛顿州。基本上，我可以少担心一点死亡。
But you know, then of course, I'm just spiraling about, well, what if the worst-case scenario happens? And what if I have sepsis? Is the helicopter going to be able to get us to Spokane in time? And just this, like, "am I going to die," "is my baby going to die," like, fear. And there's no guarantees.
但你知道，然后当然，我开始纠结，如果最坏的情况发生了怎么办？如果我得了败血症怎么办？直升机能及时把我们送到斯波坎吗？还有这种，“我会死吗”、“我的宝宝会死吗”这样的恐惧。而且没有任何保证。
For anyone-- pregnant person, doctor, anyone-- who might want to look at the maternal mortality statistics in Idaho since the new laws passed, the state used to have a committee that tracked maternal deaths and their causes. But it doesn't anymore. The legislature decided not to renew it in its last session. Idaho is now the only state in the country without a committee like this.
对于任何——孕妇、医生，任何可能想要查看新法律通过后爱达荷州孕产妇死亡统计数据的人来说，该州曾经有一个委员会来追踪孕产妇死亡及其原因。但现在没有了。立法机关在上届会议中决定不再续期。爱达荷州现在是全国唯一没有此类委员会的州。
So that's the situation for these women who just needed general OB/GYN care during their pregnancies. But then there are the high-risk patients, which includes, by the way, anyone who's expecting twins, anyone with high blood pressure or diabetes, anyone over 35, and anyone whose pregnancies include rare complications. These people are in a much more dire situation in Idaho now, because they may need what's called a maternal fetal medicine doctor. These are highly skilled OB/GYNs, specialists at keeping both the fetus and the patient alive and healthy through these pregnancies. And these doctors have been leaving the state.
这就是那些在怀孕期间只需要一般妇产科护理的女性的情况。但还有高危病人，顺便说一句，包括任何怀双胞胎的人，任何有高血压或糖尿病的人，任何超过35岁的人，以及任何怀孕有罕见并发症的人。这些人现在在爱达荷州处于更加严峻的境地，因为他们可能需要所谓的母胎医学医生。这些是高技能的妇产科医生，擅长在这些妊娠中让胎儿和病人都保持生存和健康。而这些医生一直在离开这个州。
Kayla Smith had a maternal fetal medicine doctor. Her first pregnancy had complications, but things were going smoothly with this one. It was a boy. She and her husband had picked out a name-- Brooks. And then, when she was 19 weeks, she went in for her anatomy scan.
凯拉·史密斯有一位母胎医学医生。她第一次怀孕有并发症，但这次一切顺利。是个男孩。她和丈夫已经选好了名字——布鲁克斯。然后，在她怀孕19周时，她去做了结构检查。
And I just remember the sonograph. Like, I know they can't say anything, but she just kept going over his heart, like, quite a bit. And so of course I'm, like, talking myself down, like, it's fine. It's just different this time. Like, each person has a different way of doing things.
我只记得超声波。我知道他们不能说什么，但她不断反复看他的心脏，相当长的时间。所以当然，我一直在安慰自己，这没事。只是这次不同。每个人的工作方式都不同。
And then, it was just really quiet. And then she left. And so Dr. Cooper walked into the room.
然后，真的很安静。然后她离开了。接着库珀医生走进房间。
Dr. Kylie Cooper, her maternal fetal medicine specialist.
凯莉·库珀医生，她的母胎医学专家。
I just remember she had a diagram, and she-- I just remember her being like, I have never seen a heart defect this severe before. Like, they couldn't really see the baby's aorta at all. Like, his-- [SIGHS] I guess-- aortic arch wasn't really formed.
我只记得她有一张图表，我只记得她说，我从未见过如此严重的心脏缺陷。他们根本看不清宝宝的主动脉。他的——（叹气）我想——主动脉弓并没有真正形成。
The only thing Kayla wanted to know was, could Brooks survive past birth? She and her husband had already decided they could care for a child with special needs, so Dr. Cooper referred her to a pediatric cardiologist. But he told her, no. Brooks's chances of survival were very unlikely.
凯拉唯一想知道的是，布鲁克斯能挺过出生吗？她和丈夫已经决定他们能照顾一个有特殊需求的孩子，所以库珀医生把她转介给了一位儿科心脏病专家。但他告诉她，不能。布鲁克斯存活的机会非常渺茫。
He called some of the best pediatric hospitals in the country, and none of them could offer her a surgical option to fix his heart. She remembers sitting in an ultrasound room with her doctor.
他给全国最好的几家儿科医院打了电话，但没有一家能提供手术选择来修复他的心脏。她记得和医生坐在超声波室里。
She's like, if you decide to continue this pregnancy, like, I'm here for you, and we will figure out what that means and where we need to go from here. She's like, but if you do decide that you did not want to continue this pregnancy, she's like, I'm just really sorry. (CRYING) There's nothing I personally can do for you.
她说，如果你决定继续怀孕，我会在你身边，我们会弄清楚这意味着什么，以及我们需要从哪里开始。她说，但如果你决定不想继续怀孕，我很抱歉。（哭泣）我个人无能为力。
And you understood at that point, like, this is because of the laws.
在那一点上你明白了，这是因为法律的原因。
Yeah. Yeah. I mean, her hands were tied. I knew, I knew she was protecting herself. But also, like, I would never ask her to be in that position. Yeah, we just all kind of looked at each other like, what the hell do we do now?
是的。是的。我的意思是，她的手被绑住了。我知道，我知道她在保护自己。但同样，我绝不会要求她处在那种位置。是的，我们只是面面相觑，想，现在该怎么办？
Most patients like Kayla, whose pregnancies have what are called lethal and life-limiting fetal anomalies, choose termination, because continuing their pregnancies will result in miscarriage, stillbirth, or death shortly after delivery. But Kayla's doctor could not offer her a termination. Just a week or so before this, terminating a pregnancy like Brooks's would not have been considered an illegal abortion in Idaho. But now, under Idaho's new laws, it was.
大多数像凯拉这样怀孕有致命和限制生命胎儿异常的病人会选择终止妊娠，因为继续怀孕会导致流产、死产或出生后不久死亡。但凯拉的医生无法提供终止妊娠的服务。就在这之前一周左右，终止像布鲁克斯这样的妊娠在爱达荷州不会被认为是非法堕胎。但现在，在爱达荷州的新法律下，是非法的。
So Kayla started asking her doctor about, what if she did continue her pregnancy and delivered Brooks's? What would it be like for him? Would he feel any pain during the birth? Would he suffer from air hunger, feel breathlessness as he gasped for air? But of course, her doctor couldn't guarantee that he wouldn't feel anything, even with palliative care and morphine.
所以凯拉开始问医生，如果她继续怀孕并生下布鲁克斯会怎样？对他来说会是什么感觉？他在出生时会感到疼痛吗？他会因为空气饥饿而受苦吗，会在喘气时感到呼吸困难吗？但当然，她的医生不能保证他不会感觉到什么，即使在姑息治疗和吗啡的情况下。
So then it just also felt like there was only one option, and it wasn't one that we wanted to make. But I don't want my son to suffer. I don't-- I'm not going to put myself through that and also risk my own life. Because Dr. Cooper kept reiterating to me, she's like, you have a 40% chance of getting preeclampsia again.
所以感觉好像只有一个选择，而且这不是我们想做出的。但我不想让我的儿子受苦。我不是——我不会让自己经历那种痛苦，同时冒着我自己的生命危险。因为库珀医生不断重申，她说，你再次患先兆子痫的几率是40%。
Preeclampsia is one of the leading causes of maternal mortality. It usually involves a surge in blood pressure that can seriously harm or kill a pregnant patient. It's unpredictable and hard to know when it'll happen and how severe it will be, which brings us to the main thing doctors find so frustrating about Idaho's new abortion laws.
先兆子痫是孕产妇死亡的主要原因之一。它通常涉及血压飙升，会严重伤害或杀死孕妇。它是不可预测的，很难知道它何时发生以及有多严重，这引出了医生对爱达荷州新堕胎法感到最沮丧的主要原因。
There's language in the law that says they can't terminate a pregnancy unless it's, quote, "to prevent the death of the pregnant woman." Dr. Cooper said she doesn't know what that means. Does it mean she'd have to wait for Kayla to be near death's door from preeclampsia before she could intervene?
法律中有语言说他们不能终止妊娠，除非是为了，引用，“防止孕妇死亡。”库珀医生说她不知道这意味着什么。这是否意味着她必须等到凯拉因先兆子痫快要死亡时才能干预？
Her whole training-- all doctors' training-- is to stop problems before death ever becomes imminent. The only other situation where Dr. Cooper could terminate a pregnancy is if the fetal heartbeat stopped, if the fetus was dead. Kayla described her options in Idaho as a, quote, "shit buffet."
她所有的训练——所有医生的训练——都是在死亡变得迫在眉睫之前阻止问题发生。库珀医生可以终止妊娠的唯一另一种情况是胎儿心跳停止，胎儿死亡。凯拉形容她在爱达荷州的选项是，“一坨屎自助餐”。
So do I risk going to term, knowing that I'm not even going to have a son to take home, and risk my life, and not be there for my daughter? I mean, I want to make it very clear that I was, at that point, 20 weeks pregnant. Like, I could feel him move. He was very active.
所以我冒着风险足月分娩，明知我甚至带不回一个儿子，还冒着生命危险，不能陪伴我的女儿吗？我的意思是，我想说得很清楚，当时我怀孕20周了。我能感觉到他在动。他非常活跃。
(EMOTIONALLY) And what that does to someone's mental health-- it's just devastating. Because I felt-- I just felt trapped.
（充满情感地）而这对一个人的心理健康意味着什么——这真是毁灭性的。因为我感到——我只是感到被困住了。
There are some really dark thoughts that I never thought I would have thought. Things like, you know, is there a chance that his heart will stop? Because I know here, where I'm currently at in Idaho, that would be a reason for them to help me.
我脑子里有一些非常阴暗的想法，我从未想过自己会这样想。比如，你知道，他的心脏有没有可能停止跳动？因为我知道在这里，也就是现在的爱达荷州，那将是他们帮助我的理由。
I heard this from other pregnant women in Idaho with lethal fetal anomalies. They found themselves wishing for the heartbeats to stop.
我从其他在爱达荷州怀孕、胎儿有致命异常的女性那里听到过这个。她们发现自己希望胎儿心跳停止。
Hearing that Brooks could suffer if he made it to term, Kayla decided to leave the state in order to end her pregnancy. She got an appointment at a hospital in Seattle, because she was so far along-- 21 weeks, second trimester. And because it wasn't clear if her insurance was going to cover it, she had to pay almost $15,000 up front. She and her husband took out a loan, and then drove seven and a half hours with their two-year-old daughter.
听到布鲁克斯如果足月分娩可能会受苦，凯拉决定离开这个州以结束妊娠。她在西雅图的一家医院预约了，因为她怀孕周数太大了——21周，孕中期。由于不清楚她的保险是否承保，她不得不预付近15000美元。她和丈夫贷了款，然后带着两岁的女儿开车行驶了七个半小时。
Kayla had a choice of how to end her pregnancy-- with a surgical procedure or by inducing labor early. Kayla knew she wanted to induce. She delivered Brooks after 12 hours of labor. He was stillborn. She says there was this weird eerie silence in the delivery room, and then everyone left so she and her husband could hold Brooks.
凯拉有选择结束妊娠的方式——通过手术或早期诱导分娩。凯拉知道她想诱导。经过12小时的产程，她生下了布鲁克斯。他是死胎。她说分娩室里有一种诡异的宁静，然后所有人都离开了，让她和丈夫可以抱抱布鲁克斯。
There were things that came up after that were kind of-- like, someone just-- people saying, congratulations, like just walking in the room and--
之后发生了一些有点——比如，有人只是——人们说，恭喜，就像走进房间……
Oh my god. Because they didn't know.
天啊。因为他们不知道。
Right. [SIGHS] Right.
对。（叹气）对。
Brooks was cremated. Two weeks later, Kayla made the seven and a half hour drive back to Seattle to pick up his ashes.
布鲁克斯被火化了。两周后，凯拉又开了七个半小时的车回到西雅图去取他的骨灰。
My parents would have, without a doubt, driven up to Seattle to get him if I needed them to, and brought him to us when they were able to come over here. But I just remember talking with my husband and being like, it doesn't make me feel good. Like, I feel like I just need to go. And he was like, then you just need to go.
如果需要，我的父母肯定会开车去西雅图接他，并在他们能过来时把他带给我们。但我记得和丈夫谈话时说，这让我感觉不好。我觉得我必须亲自去。他说，那你就必须去。
And so I drove-- I drove over to Seattle with my daughter. It was one of those things that I was like, I just need to be in charge of this, so I know what's happening.
所以我开车——我带着女儿开车去了西雅图。这是那种我觉得我必须负责的事情，这样我才知道发生了什么。
Kayla was the first case like this that her doctor, Dr. Cooper, handled after Idaho's abortion laws changed, her first case where she couldn't do anything to help. Then there were more patients like Kayla she couldn't help. And in April of this year, she was the first maternal fetal medicine doctor to leave Idaho because of its abortion laws.
凯拉是爱达荷州堕胎法修改后，她的医生库珀医生处理的第一个此类病例，第一个她无法提供任何帮助的病例。然后还有更多像凯拉那样她无法帮助的病人。今年4月，她是第一位因堕胎法离开爱达荷州的母胎医学医生。
There was already a shortage of these specialists in Idaho before the laws went into effect-- only nine in the entire state. Now, there are just five, and one of those will retire before the end of the year.
在法律生效前，爱达荷州这类专家就已经短缺了——整个州只有9位。现在，只有5位了，其中一位将在年底前退休。
That fear that every pregnant woman I talked to in Idaho had, that they'd be left totally on their own in a medical emergency, it happened to Becca, the last patient Dr. Cooper had to tell, I'm sorry, I can't help you, before she moved out of Idaho.
我在爱达荷州采访的每位孕妇都有的那种恐惧，担心自己在医疗紧急情况下会被完全孤立，这发生在贝卡身上，她是库珀医生在离开爱达荷州前不得不告诉“对不起，我无法帮助你”的最后一位病人。
Becca is 31. She lives in the Boise area and used to oversee a fitness club. She went to college on a pole-vaulting scholarship.
贝卡31岁。她住在博伊西地区，以前管理一家健身俱乐部。她上大学时获得过撑竿跳奖学金。
When she was about 16 weeks pregnant, she learned that her fetus had a genetic anomaly. Multiple organs were developing abnormally, including its heart and kidneys. If she continued the pregnancy, she'd likely miscarry and was at risk for preeclampsia or severe hemorrhaging.
怀孕约16周时，她得知胎儿有遗传异常。多个器官发育异常，包括心脏和肾脏。如果她继续怀孕，她很可能会流产，并面临先兆子痫或严重出血的风险。
You know when you see in movies, and people get, like, a fatal diagnosis, and they just kind of go numb, and all you hear is a blabbering doctor in the background? And I don't actually remember a whole lot of that conversation. I just remember sitting there and trying not to bawl my eyes out.
你知道在电影里看到的吗，人们得到致命诊断，然后变得麻木，背景里你只能听到医生含糊不清的声音？我不记得那次谈话的很多细节了。我只记得坐在那里，努力不让自己嚎啕大哭。
Because we'd wanted this one. We wanted to grow our family. We tried for almost a whole year for this one. And we told people. We were like, yeah, we're pregnant. It's going to be exciting, you know. And we think it's going to be a little girl or something, you know.
因为我们要了这个孩子。我们想扩大家庭。我们尝试了将近一年才怀上这个。我们告诉了别人。我们说，是的，我们怀孕了。这会很令人兴奋，你知道的。我们觉得可能是个小女孩什么的，你知道。
She decided to make the same choice Kayla made-- leave the state. Becca drove to Portland, Oregon, to terminate her pregnancy at a clinic. But that's not what she and her husband told their family and friends.
她决定做出和凯拉一样的选择——离开这个州。贝卡开车去俄勒冈州的波特兰，在一家诊所终止了妊娠。但那不是她和丈夫告诉家人和朋友的。
We were not comfortable being outright and telling them exactly why we were going to Portland. So we told family and friends that we were going for genetic testing.
我们不习惯直白地告诉他们我们去波特兰的确切原因。所以我们告诉家人和朋友，我们是去做基因检测。
Yeah.
是的。
Just because it is so controversial right now in our state, and we didn't want to risk losing good relationships if it came down to it.
仅仅因为这在我们的州现在非常有争议，如果万一出事，我们不想冒着失去良好关系的风险。
Becca's story is different from Kayla's, because she wasn't able to get the full procedure. The night before her appointment for a surgical termination, she started miscarrying. It was around midnight. She was at a hotel with her husband and two-year-old daughter, who were sleeping.
贝卡的故事与凯拉不同，因为她没能完成完整的手术。在手术终止预约的前一天晚上，她开始流产。大约在午夜。她和丈夫以及两岁的女儿在酒店里，女儿正在睡觉。
And I was just laying in bed, and I started counting and counting. And contractions were happening every 30 seconds. And so the only thing that I kept thinking to myself was like, oh, no, this is-- it's happening.
我只是躺在床上，开始计数。宫缩每30秒发生一次。所以我脑子里一直在想的就是，哦不，这是——它正在发生。
And so the only thing I could think of was to lay on my side, to breathe through it and relax, and just think to myself, like, I have to keep this thing in. I've got less than eight hours. I've got to keep it in, got to keep it in.
所以我唯一能想到的就是侧卧，通过呼吸来缓解，心里想着，我必须把这东西留住。我还不到八小时。我必须留住它，留住它。
The clinic didn't open until the morning. So Becca woke her husband, who phoned the clinic's on-call doctor. Becca says the doctor told them she'd be fine. She was just cramping.
诊所直到早上才开门。所以贝卡叫醒了丈夫，他给诊所的值班医生打了电话。贝卡说医生告诉他们她会没事的。她只是在痉挛。
Her contractions continued to get more intense, surging, and then backing off. Her husband kept going out to the hotel hallway to call the doctor again. They thought about getting an ambulance but knew their insurance wouldn't cover it.
她的宫缩变得越来越强烈，起伏，然后又减弱。她丈夫不断去酒店走廊再次给医生打电话。他们想过叫救护车，但知道保险不承保。
Becca says she forced herself to not make a sound-- no crying or groaning. Her daughter was sleeping in a Pack 'n Play near her, and she didn't want to wake her up and scare her. Then what happens next gets graphic.
贝卡说她强迫自己不出声——不哭也不呻吟。女儿在附近一个便携式婴儿床里睡觉，她不想吵醒她吓到她。然后接下来的事变得很血腥。
And then, right around 4 o'clock is when it-- all of a sudden, like, it was just a consistent, intense, just curdling, like, you-want-to-scream-and-grit-your-teeth contraction. And it lasted what seemed like forever. And then, the pressure was completely gone.
然后，就在4点左右，它——突然间，那是一种持续、强烈、令人抓狂的宫缩，你想尖叫，咬紧牙关的那种。持续的时间看起来仿佛永远。然后，压力完全消失了。
And then, all of a sudden, I started leaking amniotic fluid everywhere. So I ran to the toilet, and all of a sudden, my body, once again, had one another-- one of those contractions, and just squeezing like you're going to squeeze all your organs out of you. And out came the baby. And I looked down at the toilet bowl, and there it was. And I just kind of sat there and just stared at it.
然后，突然间，我开始到处漏羊水。所以我跑到厕所，突然间，我的身体又一次，有了一次——宫缩，就像要把你所有的器官都挤出来一样。孩子出来了。我看着马桶里，它就在那儿。我只是坐在那里盯着它。
Becca got into the hotel shower, and again says she didn't make a sound, even when her husband was trying to get her uterus to contract so she'd stop bleeding, which meant kneading his fist into her lower abdomen, the way the doctor instructed him over the phone. She says it was incredibly painful.
贝卡走进酒店淋浴间，再次表示她没有发出任何声音，即使她丈夫试图让她的子宫收缩以停止出血，这意味着按照医生的电话指示，把他的拳头揉进她的下腹部。她说那极其痛苦。
And so laying in the shower and-- is just streams of blood going into the drain. And the whole time, you're just like, why is this happening? This should not be happening.
所以躺在淋浴间里——血流如注。整个过程中，你只是想，为什么会发生这种事？这不应该发生的。
If Becca had been able to get a termination in Idaho, it probably wouldn't have. Her doctor, Kylie Cooper, could have done the procedure as soon as she decided. Becca would have been in and out in a day, not in a hotel room far from home.
如果贝卡能在爱达荷州进行终止妊娠，这很可能不会发生。她的医生凯莉·库珀可以在她决定时就立即进行手术。贝卡当天就能来回，而不是住在一间远离家乡的酒店房间里。
In the morning, when the clinic opened up, a couple of employees showed up to collect the fetus. Becca then hobbled over to the clinic for an exam. It was next to her hotel, and she had to walk past a line of anti-abortion protesters. Her husband had to stay behind to watch their daughter.
早上，诊所开门时，几名员工过来收集胎儿。贝卡随后步履蹒跚地走到诊所接受检查。它就在她酒店隔壁，她不得不经过一排反堕胎抗议者。她丈夫必须留在后面照顾女儿。
When she came back, they drove home to Idaho, seven hours. They sat silently almost the whole way.
当她回来后，他们开了七个小时的车回到爱达荷州。几乎一路上一言不发。
Before talking to Kayla and Becca, one part of the post-Roe experience I'd never heard about was that people who had to travel out of state to terminate safely had all these complications figuring out what to do with the remains, because of rules about traveling across state lines with human remains. Becca had wanted to donate the body for medical research to give her pregnancy loss more meaning. But for logistical reasons at the clinic, she didn't get that option. Becca and her husband decided to cremate, but they had no idea when the clinic would send the remains.
在与凯拉和贝卡交谈之前，关于罗伊案后体验我从未听说过的一点是，那些必须前往外州以安全终止妊娠的人，因为关于携带人类遗骸跨越州界的规则，在处理遗骸方面遇到了所有这些并发症。贝卡曾想捐献遗体用于医学研究，以使她的妊娠丢失更有意义。但由于诊所的后勤原因，她没能得到那个选项。贝卡和丈夫决定火化，但他们根本不知道诊所什么时候会寄回遗骸。
A couple of weeks later, we're home, and a postal worker comes up to our door and was like, hey, I'm here. You need to sign for a package. And I was like, oh, OK. There's this white box that says, "remains," labeled on every single side of the box.
两周后，我们在家，邮递员来到门口说，嘿，我到了。你需要给包裹签收。我说，哦，好吧。有一个白色盒子，每一面都贴着“遗骸”的标签。
For some reason, the box was addressed to baby and not the parents.
由于某种原因，盒子上写的收件人是婴儿，而不是父母。
And the postal worker doesn't actually realize it until I was signing for it, and she saw the name on the top, and her face just fell. And she was like, OK, bye, and immediately just left. And I was just like-- [SIGHS]. So I just grabbed the box and shut the door and just sat down.
邮递员直到我签收时才真正意识到，当她看到上面的名字时，她的脸色沉了下来。她说，好的，再见，然后立即离开了。我只是——（叹气）。所以我抓起盒子关上门，坐了下来。
As a terrible coda to a terrible experience, back home, Becca worried that people who'd helped them go out of state might get in trouble if she talked about it. It wasn't clear who a prosecutor might go after. So in the earliest, hardest days, she had a secret instead of just a loss.
作为一次可怕经历的可怕尾声，在家里，贝卡担心那些帮助他们去外州的人如果她说出去会遇到麻烦。检察官可能会追究谁还不清楚。所以在那最早期、最困难的日子里，她藏着一个秘密，而不仅仅是一个损失。
I didn't feel like I could openly talk about it. And so a lot of the grieving process, at least for me, is being able to talk about it, write about it, like, you know, even just sympathize or empathize with other people who've gone through similar situations. People-- they just don't-- it made it a muted and quiet, very lonely grieving process.
我觉得我无法公开谈论它。所以悲伤过程的很大一部分，至少对我来说，是能够谈论它、写下来，甚至只是对那些经历过类似情况的人表示同情或感同身受。人们——他们就是不——这使它成为了一个沉闷、安静、非常孤独的悲伤过程。
Becca and Kayla met recently. They're part of a group of people, with other patients and doctors, who are trying to sue the state, hoping to expand the exceptions in the abortion laws to include lethal fetal anomalies like the ones they had in their pregnancies. And most important, they want the law to allow doctors to provide abortions to preserve a person's health, not just to prevent their death, which is the language in the law right now.
贝卡和凯拉最近见了面。她们是一群人的一部分，和其他病人和医生一起，试图起诉这个州，希望扩大堕胎法中的例外，以包括像她们怀孕时那样的致命胎儿异常。最重要的是，她们希望法律允许医生为了保护人的健康而提供堕胎服务，而不只是为了防止死亡，这是法律现在的表述。
Their case was filed by the Center for Reproductive Rights, who filed similar legal actions in other states with restrictive laws. They represented the abortion clinic in the Supreme Court case that overturned Roe.
她们的案件由生殖权利中心提交，该中心在其他有限制性法律的州也提交了类似的法律诉讼。他们代表了最高法院推翻罗伊案一案中的那家堕胎诊所。
I contacted the two Idaho lawmakers in the House and Senate who sponsored the law that criminalizes abortion. I wanted to find out how they think it's working. Were they hearing about the kinds of experiences I was? Did they know about the doctors leaving the state? Do they think they need to make any changes?
我联系了爱达荷州众议院和参议院中赞助将堕胎定为刑事犯罪法律的两名议员。我想看看他们认为这运作得如何。他们是否听到了我听到过的那些经历？他们是否知道医生正在离开这个州？他们认为需要做任何修改吗？
One of the law's sponsors declined an interview, and the other didn't respond to multiple requests. So I reached out to Republican lawmakers who voted for the law back in 2020, before Roe fell.
该法律的赞助者之一拒绝了采访，另一位没有回应多次请求。所以我联系了2020年罗伊案倒台前投票支持该法律的共和党议员。
Senator Jim Guthrie represents a district in southern Idaho and identifies as pro-life. I was surprised he walked into the interview with a notebook with stats about the number of doctors who had left the state and started citing them. So far, it's at least 19 doctors. That worried him.
吉姆·格思里参议员代表爱达荷州南部的一个选区，自认为是“拥护生命派”。令我惊讶的是，他带着一本笔记本走进了采访，上面有关于离开该州的医生人数的统计数据，并开始引用它们。目前，至少有19名医生。这让他担心。
I'm pro-life, but I think there's got to be some consideration for the docs as they practice, that they're not going to find themselves in court. The second is the health of the mom. Because when you talk about pro-life, the life of a mother is-- if you're trying to protect that, that's pro-life, too, to me.
我是拥护生命派，但我认为在医生执业时，必须考虑到他们不会发现自己身陷法庭。第二个是母亲的健康。因为当你谈论拥护生命时，母亲的生命是——如果你试图保护这一点，对我来说，这也是拥护生命。
When you first voted for the abortion laws, did you think that Roe would actually fall, or did it feel more like a symbolic act at that time?
当你第一次投票支持堕胎法时，你认为罗伊案真的会倒台吗，还是当时感觉更像是一种象征性的行为？
That's a good question. And I think, to answer that honestly, probably didn't think it would happen. Because it had gone on for, what, 50 years? Something like that?
这是个好问题。而且我想，诚实回答的话，大概没认为会发生。因为它已经持续了，什么，50年了？大概这样？
He's the chair of a committee in the Senate that abortion bills go through before they go to the rest of the legislature for a vote. He says the language in the abortion ban was always more aggressive than his own personal beliefs.
他是参议院一个委员会的主席，堕胎法案在提交给立法机关进行投票前会经过该委员会。他说堕胎禁令中的措辞一直比他个人的信念更激进。
At that time when you voted for them, were you looking that closely at the language of the laws?
在你们投票支持它们的时候，你们有那么仔细地审视法律的措辞吗？
You know, maybe there was some things overlooked, as far as what the consequences would be, because they weren't truly consequences yet. In your subconscious, you're thinking, it's not going to be overturned, so this is one way you can make a statement. You kind of get into that deal where if you're pro-life, even though the bill has some things that are problematic, you know, you're going to come down on the side of erring on the side of protecting the unborn.
你知道，也许有一些事情被忽视了，至于后果会是什么，因为它们还不是真正的后果。在你的潜意识里，你会想，它不会被推翻，所以这是一种你可以发表声明的方式。你陷入了那种交易中，如果你是拥护生命派，即使法案有一些令人头疼的问题，你知道，你还是会站在保护未出生者的这一边。
Like the other lawmakers I talked to, he says he believed the intent of the laws, when he voted for them, was to shut down abortions happening in clinics in the state, not to help shut down a rural labor and delivery unit or force patients to travel out of state because of severe fetal abnormalities. Those were consequences he didn't foresee.
像我交谈过的其他立法者一样，他说他相信法律投票时的初衷是关闭在该州诊所发生的堕胎，而不是为了关闭乡村产科单位或迫使病人因胎儿严重异常而前往外州。那些是他没预见到的后果。
Now, seeing how things have played out, do you regret voting for those laws, or would you have done something different if you could go back in time?
现在，看到事情的发展，你后悔投票支持那些法律吗，或者如果你能回到过去，你会做些不同的事情吗？
In the context of being pro-life and recognizing the importance of the unborn, I feel like that vote at that time, with what was in place as far as trying to push back against an embedded law, I think that was an appropriate vote at the time, even though once the Roe versus Wade was overturned is when the reality, I think, sunk in for all of us.
在拥护生命和认识到未出生者重要性的背景下，我觉得那时的投票，考虑到当时试图推动抵制嵌入式法律的立场，我觉得那在当时是适当的投票，尽管一旦罗伊诉韦德案被推翻，我想现实对我们所有人来说才真正沉淀下来。
I talked to three Republican legislators, and they were all in the same situation, trying to grapple with the consequences of what had just been theoretical policy when they first voted for them, but now was real law, affecting real situations in people's lives. Where Republican lawmakers used to be pretty much on the same side, now they have different ideas about how to apply pro-life to Idaho's new laws.
我和三名共和党立法者交谈，他们都处于同样的情况，试图应对他们第一次投票支持时只是理论上政策、但现在已是现实法律的后果，这些现实情况影响着人们生活中的实际处境。共和党立法者曾经几乎都在同一边，但现在他们对如何将“拥护生命”应用于爱达荷州的新法律有不同的看法。
The next lawmaker I talked to was Representative Brent Crane. For nearly 20 years, he's represented a district outside of Boise and makes his living running a fire alarm and security business. He believes in life at conception and says he's proudly sponsored or co-sponsored more than a dozen pieces of anti-abortion legislation.
我交谈的下一位立法者是众议员布伦特·克兰。近20年来，他代表了博伊西郊外的一个选区，以经营火灾报警和安防业务为生。他相信受孕即生命，并说他自豪地赞助或共同赞助了十几项反堕胎立法。
He and Senator Guthrie are on the same page, as far as seeing the need to broaden exceptions in the abortion laws. But they also have to work alongside lawmakers who think there shouldn't be any exceptions-- for instance, for rape and incest victims. Representative Crane describes them as still stuck in what he calls a pre-Roe mindset, where everything is still black and white. He says he used to view abortion that way, too, until Roe finally fell.
他和格思里参议员在看到扩大堕胎法中例外的必要性方面意见一致。但他们也必须与认为不应该有任何例外的立法者共事——例如，针对强奸和乱伦受害者。克兰众议员形容他们仍然困在他所说的罗伊案前的思维方式中，一切仍然是非黑即白。他说他以前也那样看堕胎，直到罗伊案最终倒台。
I remember sitting by the fireplace with my wife. That's usually where we sit and download in the evening or early morning. And I said, I've got to get my head around this issue, because we are not prepared to deal with this as a state.
我记得坐在壁炉边和我妻子在一起。那通常是我们晚上或清晨坐下来交流的地方。我说，我必须搞清楚这个问题，因为作为一个州，我们没有准备好处理这个问题。
What did you mean by that?
你那是什么意思？
A post-Roe environment is totally different. In pre-Roe, all legislation was crafted to try to set questions up before the court. Well, now, you're in a post-Roe environment where you have to govern. And that means you have to have legislation that is going to work.
罗伊案后的环境完全不同。在罗伊案前，所有立法都是为了在法院前提出问题。好吧，现在，你处于罗伊案后的环境，你必须执政。这意味着你必须有能够运作的立法。
And for a pro-life lawmaker-- most pro-life lawmakers will take a very conservative and very rigid stance on the issue of life. Like, no, I'm not-- I'm not going to give any ground at all for any more exemptions. That's it. Whatever. For me, personally, I think that there are some instances where the families need to make those decisions.
而对于拥护生命的立法者来说——大多数拥护生命的立法者会在生命问题上采取非常保守和僵化的立场。比如，不，我——我绝不会为任何豁免做出让步。就这样。无论如何。对我个人而言，我认为在某些情况下家庭确实需要做出那些决定。
Again, this is a place where lawmakers who used to all be on the same side of abortion are now in conflict. And there was a draft of a bill in the last legislative session that got to the main problem with the current law, the way OB/GYNs see it. The bill would have allowed abortions for some serious health complications before they became life-threatening-- in other words, letting doctors make decisions based on the health of the pregnant person, not just their potential death.
再说一次，这是一个以前在堕胎问题上都站在同一边的立法者现在陷入冲突的地方。在上届立法会议中有一份法案草案触及了当前法律的主要问题，也就是妇产科医生所看到的。该法案允许对一些严重的健康并发症进行堕胎，即使在它们变得危及生命之前——换句话说，让医生基于孕妇的健康而不是仅仅基于她们的死亡做出决定。
Representative Crane chairs the House committee that abortion legislation goes through. And he scheduled a hearing for the bill that he had to cancel at the last minute because he didn't have the votes to get it out of committee. For some of his members, considering the health of the pregnant person opened a can of worms.
克兰众议员主持了堕胎立法必须经过的众议院委员会。他为该法案安排了一场听证会，但在最后一刻不得不取消，因为他没有足够的票数让它走出委员会。对他的一些成员来说，考虑孕妇的健康开启了一个潘多拉的盒子。
Behind closed doors, that was part of the debate. And then, if we're opening health of the mother, where does that stop? Is it mental health? Is it just tied to physical health? Is it financial health? What is-- how are you defining health of the mother?
在闭门会议中，那是辩论的一部分。然后，如果我们开放母亲的健康，这到哪里为止？是心理健康吗？是仅仅与身体健康相关吗？是财务健康吗？什么是——你如何定义母亲的健康？
Representative Julianne Young is a Republican from southeastern Idaho. She's vice chair of that committee, and opposed that new language about health complications.
朱莉安·杨众议员是来自爱达荷州东南部的共和党人。她是该委员会的副主席，反对关于健康并发症的新语言。
What I don't want to do is put language in that's so vague that it has the effect of opening the door to abortion in situations where you could protect both lives. And so if we're talking about high blood pressure, if we're talking about conditions that are common to pregnancy, then we don't want that lumped into anything that could be a life-threatening condition for the mother. Because the reality is that as women, we put our lives on the line by choosing to have children. There are always risks with every pregnancy, and you can never eliminate every risk.
我不想做的是加入如此模糊的措辞，以至于在可以保护两条生命的情况下打开了堕胎之门。所以如果我们谈论高血压，如果我们谈论怀孕常见的疾病，那么我们就不希望把它混入任何可能成为母亲危及生命的情况。因为现实情况是，作为女性，我们通过选择生孩子把生命押在赌桌上。每次怀孕都有风险，你永远无法消除所有风险。
What is your-- yeah, what's your medical knowledge of pregnancy?
你的——是的，你对怀孕有什么医学知识？
Oh, well, I'm not going to claim to be an OB/GYN, but I've learned a lot-- (LAUGHING) over the years. And you know, I guess I speak to the issue not as a medical professional but as a mother. That's really where my expertise is.
哦，嗯，我不会自称是妇产科医生，但我多年来学到了很多——（笑）知识。而且你知道，我想我发言不是作为医学专业人士，而是作为母亲。那才是我的专业领域所在。
She has 10 children. She switches off bringing her youngest two to the Capitol with her, and they sit in on committee meetings and hearings. Also, random fact-- turns out my uncle was her orthodontist when she was a kid.
她有10个孩子。她轮流带着两个最小的孩子去国会大厦，他们会旁听委员会会议和听证会。另外，随机事实——原来我叔叔是她小时候的正畸医生。
Representative Young is wary of letting doctors consider the health of the pregnant person, of giving doctors in Idaho hospitals the kind of control they had before Roe fell. For Representative Young, the sweep of the new laws is not some overreach. It is the point.
杨众议员警惕让医生考虑孕妇的健康，警惕赋予爱达荷州医院医生罗伊案倒台前那样的控制权。对于杨众议员来说，新法律的范围并不是某种越权。这才是重点。
The concern, I think, with the health exception is that we have some in the medical community who have practiced in an environment for a lot of years where the life of the child was not valued equally.
我认为对健康例外的担忧是，我们在医学界有一些人，他们在一个孩子生命不被同等重视的环境中工作了多年。
Are you talking about in Idaho hospitals specifically or--
你是在特别谈论爱达荷州的医院还是——
Around the country. Because that was the way it was. It was a fetus. It was a clump of cells. And there wasn't the protection in the courts for the life of the child.
全国各地。因为以前就是那样。它是一个胎儿。它是一团细胞。在法院中对孩子的生命没有保护。
Unlike Senator Guthrie, who is worried about doctors leaving Idaho, Representative Young thinks that some Idaho OB/GYNs are exaggerating their fears about prosecution under the law. She says others are scaring themselves by overthinking the phrase, "to prevent death." She points to language in the law that says they can use their, quote, "good-faith medical judgment."
不像担心医生离开爱达荷州的格思里参议员，杨众议员认为一些爱达荷州的妇产科医生夸大了他们对法律下被起诉的恐惧。她说其他人通过过度思考“防止死亡”这个短语来吓唬自己。她指出了法律中的语言，称他们可以使用他们的，引用，“善意的医疗判断。”
Representative Crane, who talked about the pre-Roe and post-Roe mindsets of Republicans, also agrees with her on this. On this topic, he doesn't see as much gray.
谈到共和党人罗伊案前和罗伊案后思维方式的克兰众议员，在这点上也同意她的看法。在这个话题上，他看到的灰色地带没那么多。
If you're not performing elective abortions, you have nothing to worry about. Just like if you're not going over the speed limit, you don't have to worry about a cop pulling you over for speeding.
如果你没有进行选择性堕胎，你就没什么可担心的。就像如果你没有超速，你就不必担心警察因为超速拦下你一样。
"Elective abortions" is a phrase anti-abortion lawmakers and activists use. But it's not a medical distinction. In medicine, any termination of a pregnancy for any reason is an abortion, whether it's to prevent death, or to help rape and incest victims, or just not wanting to be pregnant. They're all just called "abortions." Disconnects like this in terminology are another frustration doctors in Idaho have about the new laws.
“选择性堕胎”是反堕胎立法者和活动家使用的短语。但这并不是医学上的区别。在医学上，无论出于何种原因终止妊娠，都叫堕胎，无论是为了防止死亡，还是为了帮助强奸和乱伦受害者，或者仅仅是不想怀孕。它们都被称为“堕胎”。这种术语上的脱节是爱达荷州医生对新法律感到沮丧的另一个原因。
OB/GYNs who have left and ones that are trying to figure out if they can stay but aren't sure if they can stay-- they're like, the law is still vague to me.
已经离开的和试图弄清楚是否能留下但又不确定能否留下的妇产科医生——她们说，法律对我来说仍然很模糊。
What's the vague-- what's the vagueness in the law?
法律中的模糊之处是什么？
The vagueness for them-- there's an exception for life of the pregnant patient. But what does that need to be? How is that defined? Is that 15% close to death? 50%? 45%?
对她们来说的模糊之处——有一个针对孕妇生命安全例外的条款。但这需要达到什么程度？这是如何定义的？是接近死亡的15%？50%？45%？
And also, there are these things that come up. This person has preeclampsia. It is going to develop. I can't say when. They're like, I just-- I can't operate in that area, because there isn't that health language.
而且，也会出现这些情况。这个人有先兆子痫。它会发展。我说不准什么时候。她们说，我只是——我无法在那块区域操作，因为没有那样的健康措辞。
So I mean, honestly, do you think that if a doctor says, hey, look, I'm going to have to take your child, goes to the dad, I'm going to either have to-- if I don't take the child, the mom's going to die, what do you want me to do? Take the child. He does that.
所以我的意思是，老实说，你认为如果一位医生说，嘿，听着，我将不得不摘除你的孩子，走到父亲面前说，我要么得——如果我不摘除这个孩子，母亲就会死，你想要我做什么？摘除孩子。他那样做了。
And you get a wildly aggressive prosecutor that says, I'm going to take you to court for violating the trigger law in the state of Idaho. You think a reasonable court of people that are made up of just honest citizens like you and I are going to say, yeah, we're going to throw you in jail for that? We're going to prosecute you for that?
然后你得到一个非常激进的检察官说，我要把你告上法庭，因为你违反了爱达荷州的触发法。你认为由像你我这样的诚实公民组成的合理法庭会说，是的，我们要因为那个把你关进监狱？我们要因为那个起诉你吗？
They're not going to. How long has the law been in effect, right? It's been in effect a little over a year. Have any doctors been prosecuted? Have any cases come forward? No.
他们不会的。法律生效多久了，对吧？生效一年多一点。有医生被起诉吗？有案件提出吗？没有。
I mean, I think what the doctors are saying is they're like, I know lawmakers are telling us that, but there is no guarantee that a prosecutor isn't going to come after me. There is no guarantee that a family member isn't going to sue me. And I don't want to have to go to court.
我的意思是，我认为医生们在说的是，他们觉得，我知道立法者在告诉我们这些，但没有保证检察官不会追究我。没有保证家庭成员不会起诉我。我不想被迫上法庭。
And I've also got kids, and I've got a livelihood. You know, we have an AG that's really aggressive. So they're like, the lawmakers' assurance of "no one's going to come after you," "you're not going to lose in court," isn't assurance for me.
而且我也有孩子，我还要谋生。你知道，我们有一位非常激进的总检察长。所以她们说，立法者保证的“没人会追究你”、“你不会在法庭上败诉”对我来说不是保障。
I understand. I mean, I spent more than almost 90 days listening to these exact same arguments. And so I mean, look, life of the mother is life of the mother. It's not this highly technical, highly nuanced argument that I think some of these folks are scared about.
我理解。我的意思是，我花了近90天时间听这些完全相同的争论。所以我的意思是，看，母亲的生命就是母亲的生命。这不是我认为这些人害怕的那种高度技术性、高度细微差别的争论。
I don't know. I mean, you're a reporter. I'm an alarm guy. For me, it's pretty simple. Life of the mother-- hey, the mother's life? Yeah, OK, then I have the ability to operate in this space.
我不知道。我的意思是，你是个记者。我是个警报器人员。对我来说，很简单。母亲的生命——嘿，母亲的生命？是的，好的，那我就有能力在这个空间里操作。
I mean, I think that's where OB/GYNs get mad. We have legislators who are not doctors.
我的意思是，我认为那是妇产科医生感到愤怒的地方。我们的立法者不是医生。
That's true. But on the flip side, you have doctors that are trying to tell legislators how to do their job. And we have constituents that are asking us, hey, this is what we want you to enact, and that's where the tension exists.
那是真的。但在另一方面，你有试图告诉立法者如何做工作的医生。我们有选民要求我们，嘿，这就是我们想让你颁布的，这就是紧张关系存在的地方。
I ran by him and Representative Young some of the specific experiences I'd heard from pregnant women and OB/GYNs-- the actual people who've been stuck shouldering the emotional and logistical burdens of the new abortion laws-- and how disconnected they said they felt from this new era in Idaho that's supposed to be pro-life and pro-family. Here's how Representative Young sees this moment.
我向他和杨众议员跑过我从孕妇和妇产科医生那里听到的一些具体经历——那些真正被困住并承担新堕胎法带来的情感和后勤负担的人——以及他们说自己与这个本应是拥护生命和家庭的爱达荷州新时代感觉有多脱节。这是杨众议员看待这一刻的方式。
So what I hear you describing a lot seems like adjusting to a new situation. And undoubtedly, there's a little pain with every change. So we just don't live in a world where everything works out perfectly all the time. And so that-- just because there's some inconvenience associated with making the policy change to protect life doesn't mean that it's not the right thing to do. Because there's always two sides to the story, and there are a lot of babies who are going to live in this state that might not have lived.
所以我听到你描述的很多似乎是在适应新情况。毫无疑问，每一次改变都会带来一点痛苦。所以我们只是不生活在一个凡事都总是完美运作的世界里。所以那个——仅仅因为与为了保护生命而做出政策改变相关的有些不便，并不意味着那不是正确的事情。因为故事总有两面性，在这个州有很多婴儿将会活下来，而如果没这法律可能就活不下来了。
And that's valuable. That's worth protecting. That's worth paying a price for, even, if it means that there has to be some growing pains associated with that.
而且那是宝贵的。那是值得保护的。即使意味着必须伴随着一些成长的阵痛，那也是值得为此付出代价的。
OB/GYNs in the state have been telling me that access to good maternal health care in Idaho has deteriorated so rapidly over the last year that the state is now in crisis. Does that feel accurate to you, is "crisis" the word that you would use?
该州的妇产科医生一直在告诉我，过去一年爱达荷州获得良好的孕产妇保健的机会恶化得如此之快，以至于该州现在处于危机中。这对你来说听起来准确吗，“危机”是你愿意使用的词吗？
Yeah, you know, I guess I haven't seen that yet. But what I keep coming back to as a legislator, if you're a physician that doesn't want to adhere to a standard of protecting both the life of the mother and the life of the child, then that may be frustrating for you. I think there's going to be some sorting out, maybe, as the standard of practice adjusts to what the statute is.
是的，你知道，我想我还没看到这一点。但作为立法者我不断回到的一点是，如果你是一名不想遵守保护母亲和孩子生命标准的医师，那对你来说可能会很令人沮丧。我认为随着执业标准调整到法定水平，可能会有一些理顺的过程。
Do you-- I mean, I guess the concern is like, if people-- an adjustment is-- yeah, like--
你——我的意思是，我想担忧的是，如果人们——一个调整是——是的，就像——
I guess what I'm saying, Miki, is I don't think that we have to desert this value of protecting life in order to have a thriving OB community. We should be able to make these two things work together. And it might take a minute to have the conversation and figure it out, but I do believe that it's possible.
米基，我想说的是，我不认为我们必须抛弃这个保护生命的价值观才能拥有一个繁荣的妇产科社区。我们应该能够让这两件事协同工作。可能需要一点时间来对话并弄清楚它，但我确实相信这是可能的。
In the year after Idaho's new laws went into effect, Representative Young and other lawmakers did end up making a few changes to the law. Some of the most notable-- abortions are now legal for certain kinds of pregnancies that are never going to be viable, like ectopic pregnancies. And abortions are now legal for rape and incest victims, if those victims do it in the first 13 weeks and file a police report. Since most sexual assault victims never report, this is still a steep barrier.
在爱达荷州新法律生效后的一年里，杨众议员和其他立法者最终确实对法律做了一些修改。一些最引人注目的——对于某些永远无法存活的妊娠类型，堕胎现在是合法的，比如异位妊娠。对于强奸和乱伦受害者，如果她们在头13周内进行并提交警方报告，堕胎现在也是合法的。由于大多数性侵受害者从不报警，这仍然是一个巨大的障碍。
But the thing OB/GYNs wanted most-- new wording that would allow them to consider the health of their pregnant patients-- legislators didn't give them that. The lawmakers say they're still working on it. But after that legislative session ended, that's when most of the OB/GYNs who left the state or decided to retire early got out.
但妇产科医生最想要的东西——允许他们考虑孕妇健康的新措辞——立法者没有给她们。立法者说他们仍在努力。但在那届立法会议结束后，大部分离开该州或决定提前退休的妇产科医生才离开。
We're living in this moment where there's a political and ideological sorting happening in many parts of the country. There are people who are picking up and specifically moving to red or blue states to escape the laws their state legislatures have passed. It just seems easier than trying to change the politics of the place where you live.
我们生活在这个国家许多地区正在发生政治和意识形态分类的时刻。有些人正在收拾行装，专门搬到红色或蓝色州，以逃避州立法机关通过的法律。这似乎比试图改变你居住地方的政治更容易。
But the big question for the patients I talked to in Idaho is, how many OB/GYNs will still be left standing to care for them after the "sorting-out" period Representative Young brought up is finally done? In a recent survey, 50% of OB/GYNs in the state said they were definitely leaving or still considering leaving-- 50%.
但我在爱达荷州采访的病人面临的大问题是，在杨众议员提到的“理顺”期最终完成后，还有多少妇产科医生会留下来照顾她们？在最近的一项调查中，该州50%的妇产科医生表示他们肯定会离开或仍在考虑离开——50%。
Miki Meek is one of the producers of our show. Two of the women in her story with high-risk pregnancies, Becca and Kayla, are pregnant again, both with girls. Kayla recently moved out of state because of the abortion laws.
米基·米克是我们节目的制片人之一。她故事中两位怀孕高危的女性，贝卡和凯拉，又怀孕了，都是女孩。凯拉最近因为堕胎法搬出了外州。
Well, today's program was produced by Aviva DeKornfeld and Nancy Updike. The people who put together our show today include Jane Ackermann, James Bennett II, Susan Burton, Jendayi Bonds, Sean Cole, Michael Comite, Bethel Habte, Stowe Nelson, and Katherine Rae Mondo, Nadia Reiman, Alix Spiegel, Lilly Sullivan, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
好的，今天的节目由阿维娃·德科恩菲尔德和南希·厄普代克制作。今天整理我们节目的人包括简·阿克曼、詹姆斯·贝内特二世、苏珊·伯顿、詹达伊·邦兹、肖恩·科尔、迈克尔·科米特、贝塞尔·哈布特、斯托·尼尔森和凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、纳迪亚·雷曼、阿利克斯·斯皮格尔、莉莉·沙利文、弗朗西斯·斯旺森、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼、朱莉·惠特克和黛安·吴。我们的执行主编是萨拉·阿卜杜勒拉赫曼。我们的高级编辑是戴维·凯斯滕鲍姆。我们的执行编辑是埃马努埃莱·贝里。
Special thanks today to Emily Corrigan, Stacy Seyb, Katie Bradish, Lauren Sanders, Leandra Wright, Jaclyn Kettler, Paige Belfry, Jen Jackson Quintano, Becky Uranga, Liz Woodruff, and Ali Block from the podcast The Nocturnists. Our website-- thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 800 episodes for absolutely free-- thisamericanlife.org.
特别感谢今天的艾米丽·科里根、斯泰西·塞布、凯蒂·布拉迪什、劳伦·桑德斯、莱安德拉·赖特、杰克琳·凯特勒、佩奇·贝尔弗里、詹·杰克逊·昆塔诺、贝基·乌兰加、利兹·伍德拉夫，以及来自播客《夜行者》的阿里·布洛克。我们的网站——thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以完全免费播放我们超过800集的档案——thisamericanlife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia-- I don't know how he snuck into the Republican caucus this week, as it's been fighting over who the new House speaker should be. He said he totally figured out how to tell when any Republican was going to vote against Jim Jordan.
《美国生活》由公共广播交换中心（PRX）分发给公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚先生——我不知道他这周是怎么溜进共和党核心小组的，因为他们一直在为谁应该成为新的众议院议长而争论不休。他说他完全弄清楚了如何判断什么时候任何共和党人要投票反对吉姆·乔丹。
They make a really distinctive-- [HUFFING] sound when they're really, really upset.
当它们非常、非常愤怒时，会发出一种非常明显的（喷气）声。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。